now wednesday cnn town hall with biden
was such a pathetic exercise
of fawning and futility i was
almost going to skip the full dissection
tonight but then i changed my mind
during the 90-minute event it was
excruciating we saw
a sitting president embarrass himself
with a combination of lies obfuscation
and purposeful ignorance and we saw a
television host
not along as the sad spectacle unfolded
and the question is whether or not we
should be in a position where
you uh um are why can't
the the experts say
we know that this virus is in fact uh um
uh is it's going to be uh or assuming we
we know why all the drugs approved are
not temporarily approved but permanently
approved
that's underway too i expect that to
occur quickly well that means you mean
for the fda
for the fda yeah so the federal drug
administration
glad that was clarified now at a time of
immense
economic health and national security
challenges facing the united states
don lemon could have done a huge public
service by
asking tough fair questions throughout
but instead most of the time he came off
more like an assisted living aid
now there's no nice way to put this i'm
sorry but joe biden's losing it
he's rarely capable of starting and
finishing
a complete thought without kind of
wandering off on some meaningless
tangent like when he was asked about
how the administration can promote
vaccines in the african-american
community
so we've taken literally mobile vans and
people to the communities to the hardest
hit communities
and it's beginning to have some impact
but we have to talk about it more
for example i was just with uh i i get
in trouble because my wife is a philly
girl a philly fan an eagles fan
i just hosted the tampa bay buccaneers
and uh and there there's a guy there's a
quarterback there what's his name man
and meanwhile the media stand in awe
if the presidency were a decathlon this
is sort of his event
right his best traits are were on
display tonight and reminded me of why
he beat donald trump last year
biden comes across in a way that i think
is difficult to demonize
it's also difficult to interpret or
figure out but
contrast those reactions with how they
poured
over trump's every syllable
i think the starting point is trump the
man
and his psychological state
many people that i speak with the
experts
think that he's evidencing dementia he
keeps
obsessing over taking a test that is
given to
alzheimer's patients it is a bizarre
bizarre thing even the president's own
supporters may be very
unnerved is there any effort to reassure
people that the commander-in-chief
is mentally stable but now
we're all supposed to think that biden's
verbal crutches
he leans on every time he loses his
train of thought
are somehow really cute but i'm not
being a wise guy now
i shouldn't make fun of it that's good
it's good
it's good well by the way i think that
is
that's happening and because look think
about this
i'm tv i teach
i'm a big dog person i'm sorry and so
it but it is i i i sincerely mean this
look no i'm not being facetious i'm not
being facetious you think i'm not joking
on autocracies democracy has to stand up
and
no you deserve no no no i really mean it
all kidding
aside i'm not joking i wish you were
joking
it's really just sad at this point for
biden
for the country and cnn
or is it common journalistic practice to
ignore it whenever your interviewee
routinely fails to answer the question
posed
what do you say to people who are
worried about a new round of
restrictions
and mass mandates and so forth well i'm
saying look
it's a little bit like when i got
elected you know
the this pandemic was out of control you
know we've lost more people in the
united states
over 630 some thousand people
than every major war we've ever fought
in the united states of america
and that's come to a screeching halt for
those who've been vaccinated
it really has not a joke let's get to um
the questions mr okay oh wait a second
there was a question
but real questions with real follow-ups
nah that's asking too
much i want to put pressure on biden
after all
oh and drum roll please
for my favorite spooning moment of the
night
one of the things though we're doing is
what i've done
we've done which my team has done
can i ask you something mr president
because um you know it's by the way you
got i don't know if you heard that you
got a pause when you corrected the eye
for we
and we're talking about we and i think
that's a commendable attribute to
to have you know what else is
commendable don
actually telling the truth which
president bidens
repeatedly struggled with last night
first on that minor issue
of how current inflationary trends
threaten the recovery
so you seem pretty confident that that
inflation is temporary but if you're
pumping all of this money
into the economy couldn't that add to it
relates to
what in fact is now needed because we're
growing
i don't know anybody including larry
summers who's a friend of mine
who's worried about inflation
wait a second did he mean this larry
summers
i was on the worried side about
inflation
and it's all moved much faster much
sooner
than i had uh than i had predicted
and i think that has to make us nervous
going forward
that's worse than i thought by the way
and on the big issue of vaccines
poor old joe was a contagion of
contradiction
we have a pandemic for those who haven't
gotten a vaccination
you're not going to get covet if you
have these vaccinations yeah
i may want to buy a little vowel on that
one
three of those democratic lawmakers have
now tested positive
for covid despite all being fully
vaccinated we've also learned a white
house official
and an aide to speaker pelosi both
tested positive for the virus despite
being
fully vaccinated just a few well within
the span of a few minutes though
biden then amended his earlier claim
that vaccinated people will just never
get infected
this is simple basic proposition
if you're vaccinated you're not going to
be hospitalized
you're not going to be an icu unit and
you're not going to die
well there's a very very small chance
anyway which is what he should have said
but that would of course undermine his
very important
vax pitch then there's the biden claim
that
unlike trump he has the world eating out
of his hand
those of you who travel abroad not a
joke not a joke
you asked you know when i went to this
g7 all the major
democracies i walked in and i know a lot
of them because of my role in the past
and they walk in and i said america's
back and they go
i'm serious heads of state i give you my
word as a biden
said are you really back reality
joe said america's back
with the stumbler in charge america's
on her back russia china germany
they're laughing at us they went from
being on their toes and held accountable
with trump in the white house
to rolling right over the u.s with biden
in the white house
now this week we learned that china's
hacked tens of thousands of public
and private internet accounts worldwide
but as the wall street journal properly
noted the allied powers announced no
sanctions
or other repercussions a coalition
against chinese cyber attacks is nice
but not if the result is nothing
well that my friends is american
leadership
under biden and that's not all
also this week biden totally caved on
the nordstrom 2 pipeline
which is a multi-billion dollar annual
gift
to none other than vladimir putin
so in foreign affairs every country's
out there right now
fighting hard for its own national
interest
except ours biden's team is undermining
america inviting
u.n monitors in to investigate and then
berate us on racism
it's not clear that the president though
is even aware of any of this
i'm not sure and when joe biden can't
think of his own accomplishments
you got to hand it to him because he's
really good at playing his greatest hits
i've had a lot of experience
internationally
and uh i mean that not the good or bad
just i have i've
chaired the foreign relations committee
i've been deeply involved i
did national security for the our lat
the
the administration with barack
okay that one thing he got right now
like the old codgers at the elks lodge
biden slips back into the past
but has trouble responding to the
present
and so did the media slavishly covering
up for him
unwilling to hold into the same brutal
standards they held trump to
cnn has lost their credibility and last
night despite
all the buildup and production and
fanfare
biden and lemon lost their time slot
and by the way they lost it to this show
by over half a million viewers
even though we air two hours later
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else